first place a whole gutted sea bass on  foil and seasoned the fish inside and  out sea bass is known as the king of the  Seas and has a wonderful sweet white  flesh start the stuffing with sliced  fennel its aniseed flavor works  brilliantly with the fish next add  capers fresh dill and slices of lemon  then dotting knobs of butter lastly add  a splash of white wine which helps to  steam the fish and create a lovely sauce  and seal tightly into a parcel this  locks in all the juices and flavor  then simply bake in a medium oven  unwrapped and here your guests ooh and  are with delight prepared in ten minutes  rat for intense flavor a stunning sea  bass that's bound to create a stir  look at your line where the string was  and look this one is gonna be amazing  next thinly sliced fresh fennel and  scatter over the toasted flatbread  then toast aromatic fennel seeds in a  hot dry pan